weil frau prien heute hier sitzt ihr
ministerpräsident deine günther
parteikollege cdu ich fordere den bund
auf die epidemische notlage nationaler
tragweite festzustellen sagte er am
dritten januar geht der
gesundheitsminister der fdp geht er
damit in schleswig holstein
also ich halte das für absolut
angemessen das zu tun also das hat ja
schon
aus meiner sicht die pandemie bekämpfung
deutlich erschwert dass man das
infektionsschutzgesetz im november so
verändert hat und die länder jeweils
darauf angewiesen waren zum genau
richtigen zeitpunkt die epidemische
notlage auszurufen das kann ja dann sehr
schnell gehen das sieht man auch in
schleswig holstein wie schnell das gehen
kann und insofern er halte ich die
forderung für absolut richtig das zu
machen und die ministerpräsidenten
werden ja auch darüber mit dem bund am
freitag aussprechen so patrick und als
jemand der da von außen drauf schaut
mich da jetzt nicht mehr mit also wenn
wenn der fdp gesundheitsminister in
schleswig-holstein das mitträgt und mit
dem fahrrad die epidemische notlage
wieder festzustellen wie kann er das tun
wenn seine fdp im bund gerade dafür
gesorgt hat dass sie abgeschafft wurde
also bundes und landesebene war schon
immer was also da habe auch schon bald
zurückkommen da haben parteimitglieder
auch oft schon sehr konträre positionen
eingenommen weil die landes bei den
landespolitikern ist natürlich auch die
jacke näher als die hose grundsätzlich
finde ich war es ein großer fehler die
epidemische notlage abzuschaffen das war
erstens das falsche signal und zweitens
ist es ja in diese vierte welle rhein
beschlossen worden man hat dann
permanent das infektionsschutzgesetz
nachbessern müssen und auch jetzt ist es
so dass es dann für bestimmte lockdown
maßnahmen noch eine rechtsunsicherheit
gibt auch wenn das
infektionsschutzgesetz gut nachgebessert
worden ist aber es war das falsche
signal ob es jetzt ob man es jetzt
nochmal fordern muss nachdem man sich
eine andere brücke gebastelt hat da bin
ich mir nicht so da bin ich mir jetzt
nicht so sicher das halte ich jetzt
nicht für kriegsentscheidend also das
ist so ein bisschen
gut die ampel hat halt damals auch auf
das entgegenkommen für die fdp das so
entschieden und da konnten sie auch alle
erstmal nicht schnell genug sein und da
war man auch viel zu optimistisch aber
jetzt finde ich ist ein bisschen das
kind in den brunnen gefallen und man
macht die sache nicht leichter auch in
der kommunikation man könnte zwar
politisch noch mal land gewinnen machen
indem man sagt wir hatten da aber recht
aber man macht die sache dadurch nicht
leicht das war ein großer fehler aber
natürlich kann man auch mit der krücke
infektionsschutzgesetz jetzt umgehen sie
das also für schwer jemanden von außen
ergie sie was sie wie sieht das deuten
aber es ist sozusagen wieder dieses
ungute gefühl wir haben keinen
wirklichen plan wir haben keine
wirkliche idee wir haben keinen kein
klar definiertes ziel und ich möchte
auch so eine logik erleben also im
flugzeug sitze ich in der ökonom economy
class zu dritt der abstand ist fast null
für alle eine maske auch wenn sie
ertrinken können so wie auch abnehmen
erzählt dann wieder im laden muss sich
150 abstand bahn es weder es geht dann
auch immer nach dem praktischen
möglichkeiten und das ist zum teil für
die leute nicht nachvollziehbar und
wissen sie wenn wir jetzt wieder eine
epidemische notlage für ganz deutschland
aussprechen obwohl wiederum die
hospitalisierung rate er untergeht und
auch die auf den intensivstationen ist
als wildes leute und die englischen
zahlen darauf hin was sie deuten auf die
möglichkeit den sack
dann würde das wieder
dramatisieren wo es nicht nötig ist
deshalb braucht man permanent die
information aber eins muss ich natürlich
aussagen die regierung sind natürlich
erst mal nicht mit so einer situation
konfrontiert egal wer in der regierung
wäre jeder hätte da auch fehler gemacht
da bin ich ganz sicher aber
jetzt haben wir das nun schon so lange
ist ja das ist so langsam mal eine klare
linie sichtbar sein müsste und das ist
sie nicht schon bei der frage die sie
vor ihn gestellt haben pflicht oder
nicht schlecht geht jetzt hin und her
die diskussion darüber zu bringen sie
wollten gerade und dann habe ich eine
frage an herrn stricken ja ich glaube
ein bisschen zwei punkte die sie zurecht
angesprochen haben die eine ist die
volle kommunikation ich glaube auch
gerade sie haben die charts zeigen die
frage wie kommuniziert man eigentlich
mit der bevölkerung damit sie versteht
was eigentlich gerade hier passiert was
ist denn jetzt eigentlich gefährlich ist
das gefährlich wenn wenn wenn dieses
virus sich schneller wenn es
ansteckender ist oder ist es vielleicht
nicht so gefährlich diese themen anders
zu kommunizieren das ist sicherlich eine
aufgabe die die man noch mal angehen
muss insgesamt
wissenschaftskommunikation in
deutschland dass das eine und das andere
ist wir haben in großbritannien ein
politisches system mit
mehrheitswahlrecht wenn da die
konservativen an der an der macht sind
dann sind die an der macht und dann geht
das auch ab dann können die im prinzip
durchregieren das ist in deutschland nie
möglich mit einem solchen system das für
realistisch organisiert ist wo sie immer
zwei kammern haben bundestag und
bundesrat haben sie unterschiedliche
mehrheiten sie haben immer koalition zu
drei jahren teilen oder drei parteien
koalition
und da werden sie nur solche
entscheidungen treffen können das ist
sozusagen ein strukturelles ich wenig
sagen nachteile aber ein strukturelles
merkmal in unserer demokratie noch
schwierigkeiten mit seinem konservativen
ich meine großmutter hat in der eigenen
partei
gut aber wir haben einfach ein anderes
system das in das sich über viele
jahrzehnte hervorragend bewährt hat das
aber in so einer situation tatsächlich
an seine grenzen kommen muss man sich
deshalb muss man sich eben auch ab und
zu mal konkrete ziele setzen ich sage
mal 1 stand es vor allem an geben an dem
sie gerade recht hatten herr lanz und
zwar hat vor weihnachten hat man gesagt
so jetzt wohl noch 30 millionen
impfungen schaffen von november bis ende
des jahres sind siehe da es hat geklappt
und auch letztlich alle an einem strang
gezogen haben weil alle plötzlich
eingesehen haben das ist jetzt echt
absolut diskret und das heißt manchmal
ist man nachher mit dem föderalismus ist
man dann auch nicht ärgert sich keinen
besseren konkrete ziele zu setzen und
die einfach umzusetzen weil doch mehr
ist es auch nicht jetzt gibt es den
neuen expertenrat dem hintern strikt
jetzt auch an gehört neuerdings um die
frage ist wie wird das im expertenrat
diskutiert was ist der plan was ist die
strategie reden wir sozusagen
perspektivisch über 2g
flächendeckend reden wir über 2g plus
was plötzlich in
hamburg hier in rede steht reden wir
über 1 g auch etwas was ich schon gehört
habe heißt sozusagen lockdown für alle
nicht
aufgefrischten wie wir heute sagen alle
nicht gewusst dass der harte ansagen
wäre
wirklich was ist ihr darin gesprochen
also ich werde nicht darüber reden was
hier im expertenrat
besprechen wir haben eine sehr
vertraulichen modus operandi gefunden
und haben wir stillschweigen vereinbart
außer die stellungnahmen die wir machen
und das finde ich total wichtig weil das
eben auch hilft da ein gutes gut
zusammenzuarbeiten also für mich
selber kann ich natürlich aber ja
sprechen was
glaube ein wichtiger punkt den da bin
ich voll kommentator ist unser problem
dass wir keine ziele im moment haben und
keine ziele definiert haben die wir in
dem ihr einkommen oder man ist
eigentlich die an dem i bedeutet weil
das hauptproblem was ja auch umfasst
übrigens interessant ist wenn der sich
wenn man sich die pandemiepläne anguckt
wir haben ja pandemiepläne dann ist am
anfang sehr genau definiert was gemacht
werden muss und je weiter eine pandemie
fortschreitet ist gar nicht definiert
die sg weiter gehen soll es wird ganz
verschwommen das bild und gerade der
übergang in eine ende nie die wir zwar
wissenschaftlich greifen können das
bedeutet dass genug grund im minute
eigentlich in der bevölkerung da ist
lernen mit dem virus zu leben es wird
dann wie so eine influenza saisonale
geschichte genau doch mal auch mit auch
tote geben wie bei der influenza auch
wie bei der installierten anderen
regulatorischen viren das leider der
fall ist über den aber genau wie wir das
praktisch umsetzen diese mathematische
formel die wir ja für eine ende nie
haben dann zu sagen das ist jetzt die
die endemische phase oder die endemische
lage in der wir sind das stelle ich mir
enorm schwer vor dass sowohl
kommunikativ aber auch als als ziel zu
begreifen welche wir können ja jeder
sagen dass eine bestimmte impfquote
erreicht sein muss genügend grund
immunität zu haben idealerweise ja jeder
ist geimpft
gleichzeitig haben wir sehen wir aber ja
das phänomen dass gerade bei omikron
geimpft
also dass es vor allem einen eigenschutz
ist vom schweren verlauf aber nicht der
schutz mehr vor der infektion so dass
hier die definition einfach enorm
schwierig ist und da hoffe ich dass wir
uns da auch im expertenrat gespräche da
für mich auch was sie beschäftigen sie
als jemand der sich ganz intensiv auch
mit diesen dingern sondern das ist was
wann ist der punkt gekommen an dem wir
sagen können so jetzt wird das ding
endemisch wie sie sagen also wir haben
quasi alles auf und das ist dann die
eigenverantwortung eines jeden einzelnen
ob er sich impfen lässt oder nicht ob er
dieses risiko geht sich nicht impfen
lassen oder nicht und wir gehen
sozusagen über in ein neues normal ich
glaube dass alte normal wird so schnell
nicht wieder geben ja ich denke es ist
ein schleichender übergang sein also es
wird nicht würde ich mir auch wünschen
wir feiern jetzt den tag wie eine
befreiung vom bios das wird es leider
nicht geben sondern wir werden im
frühjahr ein abfall haben der
infektionszahlen aber dann beginnt die
harte arbeit denn dann muss man das
gesundheitssystem also man muss man die
kurzfristigen und langfristigen ziele
stecken das gesundheitssystem
neugierigen
krisenresistenter zu machen wir müssen
weiter mit der impfkampagne gehen wir
müssen sehen ob man angepasste
impfstoffe bei omikron habt ich finde
die impfpflicht debatte da ein bisschen
fehl am platz weil das ist ja anderes ja
anderes thema aber wir haben einen
impfstoff bionicon jetzt hat man aus
israel gesehen auch bei der vierten
impfungen eigentlich auch genauso kurz
den schutz vor der infektion nur bietet
so dass wir ja nicht eine dauerhafte
impfung haben können es ist vor allem
ein eigenschutz den wir mit dieser
impfung gegen omikron erzeugen
vielleicht haben wir in der zukunft
einen besseren impfstoff der auch in
sterilen schutzmacht ihn haben wir aber
steriler schutz heißt schutz vor der
infektion wirklich schutz vor infekten
die krankheit geben
in den usa medikamente mehrere
medikamente
taugen die was können sie was dazu sagen
gleich eins nach dem anderen ich finde
nur ganz kurz über impfpflicht weil sie
sagten ja irgendwie leben schräge
debatte und die mantas ihre noch junge
blick in die runde zwei top juristen
hiervon kraftwerk als politische
beobachter in wenn ich das kurze
ausführen darf dann also wieder
wir haben ja zwei mal im pflicht gehabt
einmal beim zocken und bei masern das
sind beides mal viren gewesen die wir
ausrotten können bockenheimer
ausgerotteten masern können wir
theoretisch aus worten was wir ja hart
versuchen weltweit sind die polio aus so
lota kinderlähmung kennen das
aber das sind wo man das virus durch
eine sterile immunität durch zwei
dreimal impfung je nach dem namen
impfstoff
nach dem virus wirklich ein schutz sein
leben lang ausmerzt immer und das gibt
es bei diesem virus nicht wir sehen bei
omikron deutlich dass sich geimpfte
zweifach bekämpfte infizieren können wir
sehen aber auch dass sich gepostete
weniger wahrscheinlich nachdem boostern
aber auch infizieren können und der
impfschutz einfach nach drei monaten
nachlässt
und da muss man eben die sich die frage
stellen wir können nicht mit einem
impfstoff ja arbeiten wo wir so häufig
neue impfen wir sollten eher bei
risikopatienten oder bei der älteren
bevölkerung im herbst und winter dann
gezielt mit einer impfkampagne wieder
reingehen eine auffrischimpfung für die
älteren die das risiko haben für einen
schweren verlauf weil man muss auch noch
mal deutlich sagen dass es gibt zwei
unterschiedliche schutzarten es gibt in
schutz vom schweren verlauf es gibt den
schutz vor der infektion
die älteren will man vor allem vor der
infektion schützen die jüngeren will man
dazu noch von den schutz vor dem schwer
gehabt wie will man dass sie den schutz
vor dem schweren verlauf haben aber wenn
sie dann eine infektion haben dann ist
das eine erkältung dann ist es aber
nicht mehr so lebensbedrohlich und das
ist diese unterscheidung die wir machen
müssen und es gibt auch nach der
zweifache impfung immer noch die these
antworten die vorhanden sind die einen
einen gewissen grunde wissen grundschutz
also das heißt aus ihrer logik entnehme
ich dass sie gegen eine pflicht sind
genauso habe ich das auch fest wie es
mit ihnen hätten ja ich bin ein gegen
ein dass man sich sein wirklicher im fan
also es war nicht gerade gegen dem von
aber gegen die impfpflicht weil weil
auch das ende nicht absehbar ist weil es
nicht wirkungsvoll genug ist auch
natürlich weil du müsstest ja dann
fliegt machen alle vier wieder
ich weiß nicht wie wir nicht geimpfte
wir haben wissen sie dass die zahl also
wir haben vorhin errechnet 14 bis 15
millionen manche sagen 20 millionen ja
wieviel ordnungsämter wollen sie denn
beschäftigen also sagen wir mal du
führst die pflicht alten dann gehen fünf
millionen sagen na schön dann gehe ich
jetzt mich und die anderen nicht wenn es
eine pflicht des boston sanktionen sonst
das ist ja freiwillig also musste
bußgelder machen jetzt sagt unser
bundesgesundheitsminister ja er will die
pflicht er will auch bußgelder wer will
kein gefängnis da irrt er sich
juristisch denn wenn ein bußgeld nicht
eingetrieben also nicht bezahlt wird
wohl sonst ordnungshaft umgewandelt
werden und du bleibst zahlungspflichtig
wenn er wieder raus bist aus deiner
beugehaft musste zahlen wenn du nichts
hast kommst du wieder an boy gehabt also
ich kann nur sagen das funktioniert
nicht und bietet ordnungsämter brauchen
werden für 15 view also dass wenn etwas
was man nicht leisten kann sollte man
auch nicht machen außerdem man das
sowieso dagegen und da würde ich in
einer begründung sagen was mich so
nachdenklich mache das ganz anders
30 prozent unserer bevölkerung
haben jedes vertrauen zur etablierten
politik von der csu bis zur linken
einschließlich der linken verloren
verloren 30 prozent der wählerinnen und
wähler sicherlich mit dazu und die
anderen auch
das macht mich so nachdenklich
wir müssen einen weg finden vertrauen
wieder herzustellen das ist zum teil die
falschen sprache es ist zum teil die
angabe falscher beweggründe es ist zum
teil eine gewisse unehrlichkeit dann
reichen auch diese masken affären und
sowas aus um das ganze also noch zu
verschlimmern die leute sind so
misstrauisch geworden und ein mangel
besteht darin dass uns politikerinnen
und politiker die nicht beirren und
nichtwähler nicht interessieren bei dem
nur die wählerinnen und wähler darüber
entscheiden wie die sitze verteilt
werden und das ist das großartige an
ehrlicher satz ja es gibt ganz das ist
doch mal ehrlich wen ich mit cdu leuten
dann rede ich mit fdp leuten mit spd
leute mit grünen
es muss uns mehr einfallen und wir
müssen mal an uns selbst appellieren
verständliche sprache war ich immer
dafür aber das mit dem bewegten ich kann
es ihnen sagen wie es läuft es wird eine
entscheidung getroffen und der nächste
tagesordnungspunkt lautet wie verkaufen
wir das an die bevölkerung das heißt du
nennst nicht mehr deine wirklichen
beweggründe sondern solche von denen nur
eins dass die mehrheit der bevölkerung
sie haben ersten trägt dafür hat er aber
ein instinkt die bevölkerung nicht
nehmen ein zufall aber sie hat eine
total das müssen wir ändern wir müssen
gründlich über uns nachdenken wo wir
jetzt machen so cent und ein richtiges
ferenc ich sage nur fünf prozent der
bevölkerung die gar nicht mitgehen so
wie es immer ist richtig 30 patienten
ist zu viel ist zu finden daher stellt
jetzt alle gerade die systemfrage
politiker könnten zum beispiel damit
anfangen dass wenn sie sachlagen
darstellen beide seiten schildern und
nicht nur die argumente die auf ihre
politische linie einmal sagen sondern
mal die andere seite mit erwähnen und
dann sagen ich bin trotzdem folgender
meinung oder würde man schon ganz viel
transparenz in die sache rein bekommen
und es stimmt ja es gibt einen hohen
vertrauensverlust und wenn man
vielleicht noch mal auf die impfpflicht
debatte zurück kommt das ist sicherlich
eine debatte die zu vertrauensverlust
beiträgt das muss man echt sagen ja
zumal vorher info hinweise dass etwas
kommt ja gefühl ist doch da war diese
bundestagswahl und es gab so viele leute
und zwar querbeet der
bundesgesundheitsminister ich gebe ihnen
mein wort darauf ja die versprochen
haben hoch und teilige halter kann man
sich ja des bundestags das ist gerade
geglaubt als ich als skeptisch als beruf
skeptikerin habe es auch wirklich auch
ja also dass das ist die impfpflicht
nicht glaube immer noch daran das ist ja
das denke ich auch jetzt debatte nämlich
wirklich auch die verlogene der debatte
die ich so in diesen 20 jahren seitdem
ich politikberichterstattung mache
erlebt habe die verlogene verlogen sste
wirklich die verlogene
angespannt ja weil jeder sagt ja
impfpflicht muss man das gut man kann es
ja diskutieren so impfpflicht steht im
raum und wenn man jetzt mal schauen was
geschieht im bundestag da gibt es ein
paar wenige die tatsächlich davon
überzeugt sind wieder lauterbach das ist
dass sie kommen müsste das sind die
abgeordneten die gerade daran gehen die
fdp ist schon dabei sich eigentlich
wieder aus dem staube zu hause ihre
eigene opposition als minister hat
gesagt wir machen eine fraktion offener
abstimmung das heißt also diejenigen die
aus der ampelkoalition nicht mitstimmen
wollen die müssen nicht mitstimmen
grundsätzlich ist das bei ethische
themen eine gute sache diese fraktions
offenen abstimmung wenn es um leben und
tod geht es ist aber in dieser kürze der
zeit wenn man nicht viel zeit hat
wirklich gründlich zu debattieren
möglicherweise schwierig es
durchzusetzen die union stellt sich im
bundestag auf den standpunkt soll doch
mal die ampel mit vorschlägen um die
ecke kommt jedenfalls kommt von den
unions abgeordneten nichts das heißt sie
werden die ampel auflaufen lassen die
linke hat sich auch entsprechend
positioniert dass er nichts kommen wird
das heißt wahrscheinlich hat die ampel
überhaupt gar keine mehrheit um eine
impfpflicht durchzusetzen egal ob sie
zwei oder drei oder vier gesetzesanträge
macher selbst wenn sie sie hätte wäre es
glaube ich in dieser situation an der
politischen situation in der wir stecken
falsch es kam ja dann noch der wir haben
ja dann drei landtagswahlen jetzt
demnächst und in schleswig holstein in
nordrhein-westfalen und im saarland also
jetzt im ersten halbjahr
2022 das heißt wenn man möchte sich auch
keiner es mit der bevölkerung verknappt
und deshalb meine ich auch dass er nicht
kommt und dass ich bin aber der meinung
so ehrlich finde ich sollte man sein das
jedoch mehr verbindlichkeit beim impfen
brauchen wenn wir uns alle hier in der
runde einig sind dass wir eine höhere
impfquote brauchen dann muss man sich
auch überlegen wie kommen wir denn da
hin zu der
erklärung in der ganzen welt gerne weil
es so spannend ist sie sagen verlogen
das verlogene was ich die letzten
zwanzig jahren erlebt habe sie stellen
quasi direkt die systemfrage dann sagen
die politiker müssen ganz anders
kommunizieren so geht das nicht weiter
wir können nicht irgendwie ein
tagesordnungspunkt machen und dann uns
überlegen die tagesordnungspunkt 2 wie
verkaufen dass da draußen ist was geht
ihnen durch den kopf wenn sie das ich
kenne viele ist richtig zum thema
vertrauensverlust was sie gesagt haben
ich kenne es ein bisschen verlogen zu
sagen wir brauchen jetzt gar kein
marketing mehr in der politik das ist
glaube ich aber
denke es ist ein ganz großer fehler
gemacht worden weil man obwohl man
erstmals in eine solche situation
gekommen ist so getan hat als krank man
bestimmte maßnahmen ausschließen
wieso aus so würde nie so arbeiten da
würde immer sagen ja ich gucke mir ich
werde die daten aus und dann korrigiert
mich eben notfalls was ich übrigens
total okay findet
der letzte stand des irrtums hat mal
jemand gesagt und auch die politik hätte
den mut haben müssen zu sagen na ja das
ist der weg den wir jetzt gehen aber
natürlich schließt können wir gar nicht
ausschließen dass wir auch noch andere
mittel brauchen werden also das war der
erste fehler und das mit der
verlogenheit ich finde dass jetzt das
ist ein ziemlich hartes verdikt aber ich
würde auch sagen wenn man das wirklich
will man kann das juristisch natürlich
begründen ob man es jetzt für alle oder
eher für die nur für die menschen ab 60
zb hat der ethikrat sich ja auch zu
geäußert aber wenn man das jetzt nicht
macht und
wenn wir diese debatte zu finden eine
meinung nicht nur in der debatte führt
und sagt dass dürfen jetzt aber allemal
und das ist jetzt eine frage einer ist
eine ethische diskussion gehört er auch
jahn spende sondern wenn man jetzt nicht
einen vorschlag vorlegt und auch bereit
ist zu entscheiden dann brauchen wir es
wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr wenn wir
erstmal in der in de mission situation
sind dann stellt sich die frage
möglicherweise auch gar nicht mehr in
dieser form also wenn man das wirklich
will und sie habe ja vorher immer gesagt
man muss man muss in einer solchen
situation muss man auch bereit sein auch
mal mutig sein und entscheidung traf man
muss ziele definieren dann muss man es
durchziehen aber jetzt eine debatte zu
führen und im monat möglicherweise
monate lang dauert ja auch das nur im
märz oder februar haben sie gesagt soll
das bis dahin sind die leute völlig
verunsicherten grammy das ist nicht wohl
weil sie nicht wissen kommt der
bundesgesundheitsminister sagte er bild
ja ja das hofft durchsetzen
interessant sie sagten gerade die wissen
wissenschaftler würde das so nie machen
jetzt haben wissenschaftler sitzen sehr
genau dass er gerade erlebt hat der sein
aus seiner arbeit kommt und seit zwei
jahren plötzlich sozusagen hinter den
kulissen auch von politik unterwegs ist
politik hautnah erlebt auch benutzt wird
zum teil haben wir schon morgens
ausführlich darüber unterhalten der
plötzlich merkt wie das spiel läuft wie
nehmen sie das wahr mit dem abstand
jetzt von von zwei jahren oder über
diese distanz
ich finde dass das eine andere frage
also wie wie ich das war nehme also die
die interaktion mit der politik
eigentlich
schon ehrlich in dem sinne dass die
wissenschaftler ihrer einschätzung geben
und die politik muss basierend auf
verschiedenen einschätzungen die sie
bekommen von verschiedensten richtungen
ihre entscheidungen treffen die
entscheidung müssen sie dann am ende
aber auch verantworten die ganz im
gegensatz zu dem stehen können wie meine
eigenen ich mal sagen was ich gemacht
hätte wenn ich guten zinssatz minister
gewesen wäre ich habe noch keine ahnung
davon erstmal punkt ich soll ja nur
politische entscheidungen treffen ohne
biologe zu sein also als erste genauso
ein expertengremium zu haben gesagt dann
hätte ich immer ein mann anderen nicht
über den gleichen mann anderen
mitgenommen er hatte gesagt sie haben ja
dass man das empfohlene solcher das
leuchtet mir alles ein deshalb mal das
so dann haben sie plötzlich
unterschiedliche auffassungen dann hätte
ich zwei mit gips und dann hätte der
eine gesagt also er hat mir geraten
dringenden maßnahmen die maßnahmen die
maßnahmen wenn ich das nicht mache
kriege ich 100000 zusätzlich infizierte
und wahrscheinlich sowie todesfälle
tetra und der andere sagt ja ich halte
das alles für überzogen und gar nicht
nötig es wurde genügend das und das zu
machen und das wird auch nicht passieren
dann kann ich die journalistin ansehen
und journalist sein was soll ich jetzt
machen aber so haben sie zum beispiel
nicht leicht gemacht wir haben da ich
mich ganz zu ende sagt ich würde lieber
den weg gehen von dem kollegen der hier
rechts von mir setzt da muss ich nämlich
wie in der grundrechte einschränken viel
lieber aber wenn er recht hat übernehme
ich die verantwortung für 100.000
infizierten so viel tod die kann ich gar
nicht über sind verstöße gegen die
mächtigen ja wissen aber plötzlich
würden die leute merken wie schwer es
ist change einschlafen